I love her and I love her when she
drives me crazy and I love her when she
makes me laugh relationships can get
messy especially in Hollywood
actors but the situation can get a bit
weird when the actor is playing your
on-screen sibling strange as it may be
the awkwardness didn't stop these actors
from Taking a Chance on Love number one
the demon hunting sibling Duo they may
have been hunting demons for the cameras
but these two spend their time off
camera getting cozy and dating while
filming their chemistry on screen
together can't be denied but it's
definitely weird to think about since
they were supposed to be playing
siblings weird as it may have been to
digest for fans of the show the
relationship was pretty serious for
these two even though it didn't last in
the end number two tis the season to be
jolly Noel brought about not just the
Christmas spirit but a bit of romance as
well Bill Hader and Anna Kendrick may
have been siblings in the film Noel but
while they were shooting they also
started dating all while keeping it
under wraps from the rest of the cast
and crew it didn't end up lasting in the
long run but it like a pretty good thing
for both actors while it did happen the
showmance is not dead number three
calling all Wizards of Waverly Place
fans while it was never 100 confirmed
the idea that Selena Gomez and her
on-screen Brother David Henry had a
fling is pretty reasonable it said they
went on a few dates but it never wound
up leading to more than just that and
while the romance didn't work out their
friendship absolutely did the fact that
Wizards of Waverly Place was a Family
Channel show definitely added to the
weirdness of it all too though number
four they knew it was weird the series
Everwood saw a young Chris Pratt and
Emily VanCamp playing siblings bright
and Amy Abbott Chris Pratt said about
the relationship himself yeah we've
pretty much gotten used to the response
of ew that's weird that's creepy for
some fans who knew the two actors only
as brother and sister the idea of them
kissing was just too strange but for the
couple themselves well their on-screen
roles were just that act
number five it can't be easy these two
actors spent a ton of time together as
Jamie and cersei's kids on Game of
Thrones so it's no surprise that they
wound up getting super close the Game of
Thrones fans had a field day with that
news their relationship on screen was
tough but luckily off-screen it was much
healthier well except for the fact that
their job was to act as siblings for the
cameras number six kiss the season of
Twilight doing a drama like Twilight
inevitably leads to some special times
on set but for Kellen Lutz and Ashley
Greene it could have led to even more
these two actors were playing siblings
on screen but that didn't stop Lutz from
getting some feelings for green as much
as the actor may have wanted to
potentially broach the dating subject he
opted to stick with the friends label
one which turned out pretty well for the
both of them that said the environment
can be intense green explained being
around each other solely four or five
years of our life it's kind of bound to
happen and obviously some of them turn
into relationships and some of them
didn't
number seven fans of Roswell this one's
for you these two actors met on set
while playing siblings on screen but
very soon after that turned into a
romance for nearly the entirety of their
time on the show it may not have lasted
but it was serious enough that the
couple kept going despite all the
weirdness around the fact that they were
brother and sister on screen
number eight it was Crush at First Sight
while they met in the 90s it was only a
few years later that these two started
dating and working together on camera
Arnett fell for Amy Poehler the first
time he saw her but it took a while
before the two actually got together
they worked together on screen in Blades
of Glory playing siblings and everything
seemed to be going pretty well between
the two of them until they split in 2012
but it hasn't stopped them from being
pals according to our net you get on
with it Sage advice dude number nine it
started with denial that's right Drew
Barrymore was not at all open about her
romantic situationship with David
Arquette the two work together as
siblings Josie and Rob Geller on the
classic romantic film Never Been Kissed
what Josie do you remember High School
it was a long time ago but when talk
romance came around Barrymore was
adamant that their relationship was not
a romantic one we also dated but she
denied it on Howard Stern
truth of the matter is they were
involved together but according to our
catch the split happened before they
even played on-screen siblings
number 10 they weren't lost without each
other these two were known for being
step siblings on screen but off-screen
was a very different story they only
dated for a year but Maggie Grace shared
that she wasn't so keen on dating actors
in the first place that said the two
still wound up being on very good terms
in the end even when their romance ended
number 11. Star Wars fans do we stand
this Mark Hamill and Carrie Fisher
better known as siblings Luke Skywalker
and Princess Leia had a bit of a romance
while working together while it wasn't a
full-blown relationship necessarily
Hamill did share that he had bragged
about his kissing talents which
eventually led to Fisher checking in to
see if they were true while the two did
become very close a romance in the long
run just wasn't in the cards for them
but they stayed close despite that
feeling more like real life siblings in
the end I'll never stop missing her
number 12. not so Sleepless in Seattle
anymore these two were no strangers the
classic rom-com Sleepless in Seattle saw
Rita Wilson and Tom Hanks playing
siblings but off-screen they were close
in a very different kind of a way weird
as it may have been at the time it
worked out in the long run considering
just how strong their friendship has
been over the years to be fair they were
married for five years before doing the
film together as siblings so the
Romantic relationship did come first
number 13. who doesn't love a day off
Ferris Bueller's Day Off was a blast to
film for the cast but for co-stars
Matthew Broderick and Jennifer Gray it
was just a bit more special the two who
played siblings Ferris and Genie Bueller
started dating while filming but they
kept it a secret from everyone around
who doesn't love a forbidden romance
this one was pretty serious too the duo
was engaged before production even
wrapped unfortunately the couple wound
up getting into a brutal car accident
after filming and it left both of them
struggling with some serious pain and
eventually the two decided to part ways
number 14. from Pals to lovers Lauren
Graham and Peter Krause may have gotten
close while playing siblings Adam and
Sarah Braverman on the show Parenthood
which was what led to their eventual
dating while working together graham was
pretty overwhelmed by the situation
explaining it gave me an understanding
of life this is how things happen and
it's completely random Graham had even
had a rule for herself about not dating
any actor types so this one was real
forbidden random as it may have been
that didn't stop the couple from dating
for a whopping 10 years before
eventually Calling it Quits in 2022
number 15 any Dexter fans in the house
alrighty so Michael C Hall and Jennifer
Carpenter met while filming Dexter on
the show they played adopted siblings
however their relationship on screen and
behind the scenes was anything but
conventional this is one of the reasons
why the two kept their romance on the
down low after they started dating while
working together they even eloped to get
married but that wasn't it the couple
wound up getting divorced while
continuing to work together on the show
talk about a complicated relationship
you just never know what can happen on a
film set these on-screen relationships
definitely feel a bit different knowing
that some of them were dating behind the
scenes but hey the Heart Wants What It
Wants did any of these catch you off
guard any of them surprise you drop us a
note in the comments
[Music]